Typically, the modules in a system are responsible for maintaining invariants.
That is, they have to make sure they are in a consistent state before and
after executing each service they provide.
The same holds true for components, which are just third-party modules.
However, the presence of callbacks makes invariant maintenance much
more difficult.
In particular, during the time when the client is handling the callback request,
the component is vulnerable.
Because it has given up control to the client,
there's a danger that the client may do something that breaks the invariant,
like make another call to the component.